I'm Caitlyn on The Bachelorette she has
to make the big decision tonight is it
gonna be Shawn or Nick what Kaitlyn has
taken a lot of flack this season but
here are four reasons we don't paint
Kaitlyn first on our list that
contagious laugh the laugh I don't know
if it's contagious nauseating I've heard
it a lot the laughter and the tears
Kaitlyn can turn on the waterworks at
the drop of a hat which is the second
reason we can't hate her she wears her
heart on her sleeve
only Bachelorette that I know that has
pride before a rose ceremony during a
rose ceremony and after a rose ceremony
she is so sincere and she's real and
she's honest number three Kaitlyn is
fearless is lighting up a little bit
this Bachelorette will also kiss and
tell she's locked lips with Ben Shawn
and of course Nick
remember that infamous hookup and the
morning after when Kaitlyn messed up
finally we love that she owns up to her
mistakes we had sex she respected the
other relationships that she was in so
she told them the truth and I thought
that was pretty admirable but the
burning question will it be Shawn or
Nick tonight I'm honestly predicting
that she's gonna go with Shawn I feel
like he fits in with her personality
more they had this instant chemistry as
for Nick and Kaitlyn's relationship I
feel like that's gonna burn out really
quickly all I know is I can't wait to
find out all right well tomorrow we will
be with Kaitlyn and her man if she
actually chooses one of them
you